problem you rent your apartment and if
you drill a bunch of holes in the wall
to mount your TV they're going to take
your security deposit solution build
your own wall put it in front of the
landlord's wall and drill to your
heart's content
not a hard project just follow these
instructions and you'll be all set
alright step 1 measure and cut your wood
step to measure your wood again alright
let's make a sandwich first layer meet
some drywall next layer plywood strength
now we're going to make the frame on the
back which is going to supply the entire
structure for the thing two end pieces
and now we're going to put in longer
pieces that go in between the two ends
this is when you find out if your
measured right you want to make them
exactly 16 inches apart at the middles
of each board the reason being is you
wanted to be the same width apart as the
stuff in the roll because if you're
going to line them up with the wall you
can put one stud into another stud so
much stronger than screenings right well
don't do that so we're going to clamp
these together to keep them from moving
apart but you don't want to clamp them
too hard because you'll ding your
drywall and then get this back away now
that you've got everything laid out time
to start screwing it together you want
to countersink the screws because you're
going to put some spackle over them so
you don't want to be flush with the
surface or else you're not going able to
get enough smooth sand now it's time to
spackle which means take this putty
smear it over the holes you made in the
board so that we painted it smooth see
how it's pink it actually dries white
all right so our spackle is dry which
means the next step is to sand it and
basically what you want to do is you
want to smooth out any bumps you left
with the spackle
our next stop is to drill the holes
we're going to drop the chords through
so this is the hole saw that came with
that grommet kit this mark right here
represents where the bottom center of
the TV is going to be I want to be just
above that so there you have a nice
clean hole so you've got your hole for
your TV next step is to make a hole for
the audio gear and video gear to send
its cables from one to the other
same deal as before cut a big hole there
are some little butterflies that come
out on the end you keep it falling out
it's a right nice finished look looks
like an actual real install so there are
almost as many different mounts as there
are kinds of TVs I like one by Philips
called simply straight these rollers sit
in these tracks and the TV automatically
levels itself between the leveling you
did with this gravity does the rest it
always hangs straight and that's the
best
Hey look at that it's magic 16 inches
apart and that is 4.25 down
when this screw goes through it's going
to go through drywall then it's going to
go through plywood and it's going to
lodge itself into a 2x4 there's no need
for an anchor in there so all you need
to do is drill out a big enough hole but
this won't split my 2x4 and then drive
it directly into the wood
because I used math the latest thing out
I know that these are both going to go
directly into solid wood there's one and
there's two
the next step is to make it look pretty
and to put it on your wall that means
you paint it and then you line it up
with two studs on your wall and you take
the four inch screws and you screw
directly through the entire assembly
into the wall crown molding don't just
leave it behind the wall first of all
your fake wall won't sit flush second of
all it just looks really cool to have
this thing finished and perfect the
great advantage of this setup is that
you don't have to worry about the slack
in your cables there's no making loops
and tying them off and trying to hide
them behind something all the slack is
behind the wall in here I've measured it
so I know the TV's bottom is going to be
right here
so you're not going to see any of this I
got my plugs plugged in my cables
plugged in and I'm ready to hang it on
the wall you put that one there that one
there it just slides on those rollers
and you're good
and that's it a little bit of elbow
grease some readily available
construction materials and an afternoon
spent playing with power tools and
you've got a nice clean custom install
and your landlord's not going to kill
you when she sees me done with the place
feeling wide yet subscribe